hallo herzlich willkommen in unserer
torten welt heute wollen wir eine
leckere biskuitrolle machen mit
erdbeeren um mit mango ich finde die
erdbeerzeit muss man jetzt in vollen
zügen genießen und muss man ausnutzen
und ich finde so eine etwa rolle gehört
eigentlich mit auf jeden tisch und sich
sehr schnell hergestellt deswegen zeige
ich euch auch gleich die zutaten für den
gehsteig und später dann für die creme
also ich brauche drei eier ich nehme
drei ist ein fleißiger 100 gramm zucker
eine prise salz
ich habe hier 90 kamel 30 g speisestärke
30 gramm zerlassene butter sie zweiter
stoffe sind fest geworden ist
elastischer nochmal unten halber
teelöffel backpulver das sind schwämme
das ist zum waschen zeige ich dir gleich
und wir geben zuerst die eier hier rein
machst du das ein finger auf ja ich
hoffe dir dabei ein bisschen salz
und auch gleich den zucker das schaffst
du alleine super und da gebe ich jetzt
gleich noch drei ist heißes wasser mit
dazu damit der teig einfach nicht wieder
biskuitteig so schön fest wird sondern
dass es bisschen flüssig bleibt und ich
das gleich schön darum verteilen kann
schaltet man hoch
es reicht schon
seitdem sei das wasser mit ein
neu
nutzt du ein fall eine aus drei
die eier zucker masse ist es schön
aufgeschlagen und jetzt gebe ich mein
backpulver mit zum mehl die speisestärke
kommt auch zum jetzt kannst es medien
geben dass sieben wir jetzt erstmal dann
ist keine klümpchen gibt
und das ganze mache ich jetzt ohne
küchenmaschine
das habe ich jetzt einfach mit einem
teil darunter das macht jetzt ich ok ich
muss nämlich den teig ist streicheln mit
einer zusammenfällt
so ganz vorsichtig von außen nach innen
zum spender zusammen ist die ganze luft
für draußen nicht schon wieder papa das
trage ich immer so viele sachen und
jetzt gebe ich noch die zerlassene
butter mit rein das ist übrigens bei mir
in der wiener master also das ist nicht
einfach ein bisschen teig sondern eine
leader masse deswegen ist auch immer bei
meinen biscuit oder beim einer wiener
masse eben butter mit dabei und es ist
eigentlich sonntag der gelingt auch
immer wenn man eben drauf achtet also
alles beachtet die trend und es gebe ich
jetzt hier in meinem vorbereiteten back
rahmen gepackt es jetzt im eckigen back
rahmen sind auch ein normales backblech
benutze aber ich nehme das immer ganz
gern weil da halt die ecken schön
rechtwinklig sind und ich dann eben aus
dem nichts wächst in den links machst du
mit deinem gleich die backofentür auf
jetzt hier einfach kurz verteilen
jetzt kommt die bis der biskuitteig in
den backofen und zwar bei mir habe ich
jetzt 180 grad eingestellt
ihr könnt doch gerne höher backen je
nachdem wie ein backofen funktioniert
also bis 200 ich alles okay der biss
gezeigt muss nämlich kurz backen damit
er einfach nicht trocken wird und ich
reiße das ist eigentlich so das
geheimnis an der biskuitrolle und ich
gebe den jetzt für ungefähr sieben
minuten im backofen
mein bis geht es jetzt aus dem ofen raus
und jetzt nämlich etwas zucker und
bestreut mein geschirr mein sauberes
geschirrtuch damit einfach damit jetzt
der bis geht nicht da dran kleben bleibt
und man schmeckt natürlich später den
zucker raus aber ich mach das so ich
nehme in der füllung einfach weniger
oder bis gar kein zucker
also nix passiert mir ist der teig aus
der hand da drauf gefallen eigentlich
machst du an das strom und in dem
normalerweise auch immer einen teig
retter mit dazu ich weiß nicht wie ich
solche zeit bis diese bizkit platte
einfach so drauf transportiert keine
ahnung
sind die schwangerschaftshormone es tut
mir leid klubs haben schnell hier eine
ecke abgerissen ist aber nicht schlimm
da machen wir einfach so dass die ecke
drin bleibt das heißt ich rolle setzt
hier auf
das machen wir jetzt so und dann lassen
wir gleich de bist getreulich hier
einfach am rand abkühle
so behält sie nämlich gleich ihre form
und das ist dann später einfacher wenn
man sie dann später zusammenrollt am
reichsten ist richtig dass ich die ziel
kurz abkühlen dauert wahrscheinlich so
15 20 minuten und dann geht es nicht
weiter
während die biskuitrolle abkühlen werde
ich schon mein obst um eine creme
vorbereiten und zwar mache ich ja heute
eine erdbeer rolle
aber die wird mit mango sein als nämlich
wie hier schon eine mango gerichtet ich
habe hier 250 gramm erdbeeren die sind
auch bereits gewaschen und für die creme
habe ich hier 250 gramm pasta frohne 400
g schlagsahne die stelle ich gleich noch
mal kühl damit sie hier nicht warm wird
60 gramm puderzucker
ich brauche etwas salat und eine bio
limette das war's auch schon
und das erste was mach ich schäle die
mango und habe ich für mich rausgefunden
das geht am besten mit so einem
sparschäler schild richtig dünn
und wer möchte kann natürlich nur etwa
nehmen oder kann auch die mango wenn man
es bei mango marc oder net daheim hat
kann man sie auch ersetzen also was ich
mir richtig gut vorstellen ist 40
entweder frisch oder auch aus der dose
ich mag auch den verdacht aus der dose
ganz gerne den stelle ich mir auch
richtig lecker vor
oder halt irgendwas anderes passiert
halt gerne habt
dann nehme ich mir ein großes messer und
halt wie mango und zwei stellen ja so
ein großer kerl und dann ist das einfach
dran vorbei als man merkt es irgendwann
an dem widerstand dann auch an der
anderen seite vorbei
so und ich brauche jetzt auch nicht
komplett die ganze man wo ich vielleicht
ein bisschen zu viel aber ich nehme
jetzt hier noch kitschig und den rest
könnte ich sah mir einfach später
abklappern so und des mango fleisch es
wirklich schön klein
und dann lege ich mir die schönsten
erdbeeren weg die benutze ich nämlich
später für die dekoration da gucke ich
dass es so ziemlich gleichmäßig aussehen
aber muss es eine dynamische
naturprodukt und erdbeere diese
unterschiedlich aussehen das reicht auf
jeden fall
und da nehme ich jetzt den rest und
würfel sind sondern schmeißt sie ihn so
lange stücke also praktisch im streifen
jetzt kann ich schon mal die sahne steif
rühren ich habe jetzt auch noch mal kalt
gestellt als die muss halt echt richtig
kalt sei an so ein stück für euch und
dann hat man keine sahne sondern butter
also falls jemand butter machen wollt
dann wird es ganz kurz verrührt und dann
lasse ich vier teelöffel vom salat mit
dazu einen rieseln und das sorgt einfach
dafür dass die spanische entstand fest
bleibt und ich sie denn gleich auch
weiter verwenden kann
und die zeit muss ich schon mal & ride
meine limettenschale ab gebe ich einfach
mit thomas capone könnte jetzt auch der
zitrone zum beispiel nehmen oder auch
weglassen
aber ich finde die limette macht heißt
es sommerlich frische limetten hat nicht
immer so an cocktails und am sommer und
einem monat zu monat übrigens arbeit
machen machen wir dann schön im garten
und dann gebe ich noch in halbe eine
halbe limite mit rein also den saft
erfahren
hier kommt es noch der puderzucker mit
rein die sahne nie aus dem auge
verlieren dass er uns zur butter gewinnt
noch ein bisserl dazu
aber ich behalte im auge und berühre
jetzt hier schon mal die mascarpone auf
niedrigster stufe erst mal
ganz kurz die sahne kontrollieren also
ich seh letzte läuft jetzt in der
schüssel noch so ein bisschen hin und
her also ein paar umdrehungen kann ich
sie noch früher
abends war echt extrem aufpassen
thomas cup honig gebe ich jetzt trotzdem
auch noch ein teelöffel seiner partei
auch wenn die mascarpone so fest ist
aber da geht einfach sicherte täglich
nichts verläuft das auch noch mal kurz
verrühren
bitter auch nicht so lange her sonst
wird die nämlich auch ganz christlich
und gerinnt euch jetzt könnte die
mascarpone ganz einfach unter die sahne
creme heben
und das ist einfach ganz vorsichtig
also ich bin so perfekt und ihr könnt
ihr auch abstimmen also wenn die
erdbeeren süß genug sind braucht man
nicht so viel zucker wenn sie ehrlich
sind oder allgemein soll die soaps nimmt
denn da einfach mittelmeer zugang zur
jedes alter rolle ich lasse aber jetzt
die biskuitrolle card doch mal schnell
fünf minuten abkühlen und dann geht's
gleich weiter und das stelle ich aber so
lange im kühlschrank
jetzt kann ich meine bizkit rolle
endlich füllen und dafür rollig sie
jetzt einmal auf und es ist halt
wirklich wichtig dass sogar komplett
abgekühlt ist
es gebe ich da die mango stücke drauf
wer möchte kann zum beispiel zu hobbys
aussagen gemacht die mangos mit noch
millimeters marinieren
dann wird zwar der bizkit eike bisserl
feucht aber ich finde es schlimm also
wird es gern möchte kann das gerne mache
und jetzt auch noch die erdbahn drauf
richtig schön fruchtig und ihr seht
jetzt schon ich mache es nicht bis ganz
zum schluss er sich dass hier hinten
immer das ende frei einfach damit das
obst später nicht rausgewählt beim
aufrollen
und jetzt geben wir hier die creme drauf
ein bisschen was was ich übrig für die
deko und jetzt verstreiche ich das schön
darüber
und jetzt wird die biskuitrolle
aufgeholfen das macht hier am besten
auch mit dem geschirrtuch also immer so
mit leichtem druck der bis kritisch
heute ziemlich fein
danke manager und dass sich halt ganz
deutlich den vorteil von dem seiner
partei auf die sahne direkt festwirt und
ich eben die rolle schön aufbauen kann
und die wird er noch echt immer schön
rund
jetzt nehme ich mir hier einfach so zwei
winkel paletten zwei lange damit ich das
einfach darüber jetzt transportieren
kann ein mann darunter einmal dort üben
jetzt richtig gezaubert zu mir
jetzt verstehe ich die rolle noch mit
etwas puderzucker schlimm da wieder den
süßen schnee weil der schmerz
jetzt habe ich mir so eine einwegspritze
gerichtet mit nahrungs hätten schüler
kann man jetzt auch ein stern schüler
oder eine andere töne benutzen ist
eigentlich egal denn damit dekoriert
jetzt die biskuitrolle noch fertig
bekommen jetzt die recht creme rein
jetzt spritze ich mich hier einfach so
ein paar rosetten drauf dass amira sieht
und dann die erdbeeren die halbjährig
jetzt und setzt sich hier jetzt noch
drauf
und so sieht jetzt die fertige erdbeer
biskuitrolle aus erdbeer biscuit mango
rolle und ich werde jetzt gleich noch
fotografieren damit ich ein schönes foto
für euch ab für facebook und für
instagram und wenn ihr diese rolle nach
machen wollt geht einfach auf meinem
blog vorbei aufs ellis blog.de dort
gibt's das ganze schriftliche rezept
noch mal und ich freue mich natürlich
auch über eure fotos und wünsche euch
jetzt noch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken bis zum nächsten mal ganz
genau
bis zum nächsten mal
und schmeckt
schmeckt auch immer